c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche passera quand je n'ai
jamais été sur teen love mais je vous
cache pas que je suis hyper tenter d'y
aller mais j'ai toujours pas été et il
faut te laisser quand même évidemment
sans l'appel fusion étant un petit peu
marié depuis 20 ans maintenant mais
juste pour voir si ça réagit la recaler
boîte de nuit
j'aime bien j'en ai même si vous avez
peut-être pas j'ai même été actionnaire
d'une grosse boîte de nuit à à bordeaux
pour y loger des enfants qui sont en âge
c'est moi qui les fais rentrer elle
était france télé voilà une mauvaise
période un moment donné la fin s'est mal
passé mais quand même des bons moments
et j'espère bien renouer de très bons
contacts avec alors les poils juste un
truc dans un touche pas à mon poste
cyril j'avais pas beaucoup hammami une
espèce de bandes autocollantes sur le
tibia les poils n'auront jamais repoussé
donc tout le monde me dit il était
complètement à berre ou à laisser là je
n'ai plus rien et ça ne repousse plus du
tout donc voilà donc ça c'est le truc à
cyril wecht gay dans l'armée c'est pas
lui qui est sur la plage après belle
histoire d'amour 1 entre - les fenêtres
le rôle de james bond
et depuis que je fais ça bien voyez le
cinéma l'a jamais fait appel à moi des
regards impatients démarré à m6 cette
nouvelle aventure c'est la même famille
rtl tout ça mais voilà un patient mais
il ya toujours ces huit quelque part ici
[Musique]